decades after Freddy Krueger's chilling
debut as one of Horrors most notorious
monsters Robert Englund still credits
his time as the character for taking his
career to new heights however taking on
the role of Freddy Krueger also
completely changed to the actor's life
Robert Englund never set out with the
intention of playing a monster like
Freddy Krueger in fact his earliest work
was in theater and from there he found
himself playing sidekicks in supporting
roles
he also played some unsavory characters
in films like eaten alive and appeared
in controversial movies like dead and
buried but playing Freddy was an
entirely new experience England told
Hollywood Chicago I had gotten typed
early in Hollywood as a southerner then
it was the best friend and sidekick
roles although playing Freddy
was a big step up from his previous
parts England has said that the reason
he got the role was simply because of
typecasting he had experience working in
the horror genre and this time he just
got to play the main villain instead of
a side character but England isn't
resentful of the fact that he was
typecast as he explained I didn't choose
to be in horror movies I just like to go
where I'm wanted one of the perks of
playing an iconic monster like Freddy
Krueger England may not be winning
Oscars or raking in the biggest salaries
in Hollywood but even though he's in his
early 70s he never finds himself wanting
for work and he has plenty of freedom to
choose the projects he wants England
acknowledges that if he'd never gotten
the opportunity to play Freddy he
probably wouldn't be enjoying the same
level of success today
he's been consistently working in
Hollywood since landing a supporting
role in the 1974 film Buster and Billy
but after playing Freddy the office
started flooding in as a result he's
acted in movies like the Phantom of the
Opera and behind the mask
the rise of Leslie Vernon TV shows like
bones and supernatural and in 2020
hosted a show on the Travel Channel
called true terror the roll literally
opened a whole new world for the actor
he told looper I started working abroad
I've done about a dozen movies in Europe
I've done movies in Africa and Russia
have done movies in South America and
Mexico lots of movies in Canada and that
is the greatest gift that was given to
me by the success of The Nightmare on
Elm Street franchise England also
attends conventions around the world
he told den of geek I don't think I'd
have this longevity without the genre I
can't believe I'm still here it keeps
changing and growing and I feel like I'm
on cruise control now I can go where I
want Robert Englund had been a working
actor for years before playing Freddy
but after Elm Street came out his life
seemed to change overnight and there's
always fans around now I mean the crew
are bringing their kids in and stuff so
I'm kind of on a little bit
suddenly audiences all over the worlds
knew his name and the film made a huge
cultural impact England told Hollywood
Chicago the Freddy phenomenon was
international I had no control over it I
realized it's best to surrender and
enjoy it because you can't fight it for
the first time he was experiencing what
it was really like to be an
international star not just an actor
with a few films and TV shows under his
belt it was a whole new level of Fame
but he simply embraced the changes and
didn't allow it to overwhelm him in fact
England enjoys the attention especially
when it comes to seeing his name appear
in different languages around the world
he told looper I really like foreign
posters especially the ones where my
name is written in Russian or Tony's I
think that's cool and some of them are
just amazing there's one from Thailand a
Nightmare on Elm Street 3 dream warriors
with the Freddie snake it's a strange
creepy poster but it's an image of me
swallowing and oscar-winning actress so
I had to have it
Robert Englund always knew that what he
wanted to do for the rest of his life
was theater after attending a
professional acting
and working in regional theater he
started to get opportunities in film but
he still valued everything he'd learned
acting in place and when he got the role
of Freddy he was finally able to put
those skills to good use again there was
so much he could express about Freddy's
character through body language and his
theatre skills gave him a leg up
he told looper I learned back in my
theater days that villains are better
written they're more complex there are
more layers and it's fun to do it when I
finally got all that makeup on and found
the voice and found the moves I realized
I didn't have to worry about what Robert
Englund looked like fear seems to be an
international language England realized
just how well the narratives in films
like Elm Street could translate across
cultures when he saw the worldwide
response to the film there are certain
primal terrors that affect all of us no
matter where we're from and Elm Street
played on those emotions the thought of
someone attacking you in your sleep when
you're most vulnerable and totally
defenseless is an ancient fear one that
we've lived with since humanity's
caveman days England told movie hole
these movies have traveled so well you
don't really need subtitles with them
because they're not that's culturally
specific everyone has this great primal
basic hook which is the nightmare the
bad dream so people can identify with
these films following Elm Street success
England accepted more offers to work on
films shot abroad where he was able to
indulge his love of travel and history
the actor has worked on movies shot
everywhere from Italy to Israel and he's
always been very grateful that playing
Freddy opened up those doors for him in
fact he says that nowadays he often
prefers working abroad he told IGN I
would never have been able to go down
into the caves in the Gordana region and
seen the original Neanderthal graffiti I
would never have been invited to Lake
in Czechoslovakia I never would have
spent six weeks putting my makeup on in
the same room that Rasputin was shot in
these are all the things that happened
because I'm Freddy Krueger pure and
simple although England is certainly
best known for his work in horror films
he also enjoys comedy unfortunately the
fact that his name and face was so
strongly associated with Freddy Krueger
in the 80s and 90s meant that comedy
directors weren't exactly knocking on
his door and asking to work with him
audiences knew him as a villain not a
comedian and England knows that he
missed out on some roles because of it
I'm sorry I I kept scaring you but I
work on Commission but at the end of the
day he's come to accept that it was all
for the best
England admitted to IGN I think in the
middle 80s there were a couple of gigs
in comedy both as an actor and director
that I lost because I was so so
connected with Freddy Krueger I wish it
hadn't happened
however he has no regrets about pursuing
work in the horror genre and sacrificing
some comedic roles because of that
decision after all no actor can really
do it all and in the long run his career
decisions have clearly worked out in his
favor if you ever found yourself lying
awake at night after watching Elm Street
afraid to close your eyes because Freddy
Krueger just might show up in your
dreams you're in good company Elm Street
has resulted in plenty of sleepless
nights for audiences over the years as
well as a few cast members in fact
England himself admits that he's had not
miss in which haze Freddy
wait a second now let me get this
straight you're having nightmares about
Freddy how's it me while shooting it not
for the original film England spent
hours and hours wearing the heavy makeup
they've created Freddy's frightening
look he got used to seeing himself
looking monstrous but every once in a
while he would catch a glimpse of
himself in a mirror at the end of a long
day and feel disoriented and confused by
his own reflection and that feeling has
haunted him for
England told this birds day occasionally
I do have a nightmare
I dream of me sitting up and I'm looking
in the mirror and it's not me it's
Freddie in the mirror so yeah that's how
you know a slasher villain is truly
terrifying when the guy behind the mask
is having bad drinks at this point you
could definitely consider Robert Englund
to be an expert on horror films in
general the genre is certainly in the
midst of a modern resurgence and England
says that after so many years of playing
creepy characters he's developed an eye
for which films will be successful and
which ones will flop so what qualities
can really make or break a horror movie
according to England it all depends on
whether or not the film offers something
genuinely unique he told flavor wire if
something is good or original it does
eventually get discovered it can take a
while but it will rise to the surface
and as you might expect England is glad
that horror is finally getting the
recognition and respect that he's always
believed the genre deserves back in the
1980s he found himself defending horror
films for their artistic merit because
they weren't taken a serious and now the
genre has entered a whole new era for
England one of the best parts of playing
Freddie is the fact that younger
generations still love the Elm Street
films although it's being decades since
the original movie was released
Freddie still scares new audiences today
it's totally terrifying because it's
based on a true story
wait what Freddy's coming for you you
can sleep when you're dead
England credits technological advances
since the first film with its
long-standing appeal although the
continuation of the franchise certainly
didn't hurt either with several Elm
Street films coming out in the years
since the original including the Friday
the 13th crossover Freddy vs. Jason fans
had a whole lot of new material to look
forward to England told nerd bastards a
Nightmare on Elm Street came of age at
the same time as MTV early Cable and
then
ths generation and the DVD generation
and then blu-ray and Netflix so I'm
probably on my third generation of fans
by now the actors said that the
digitally remastered versions of the
films represented a significant
improvement in quality adding the movies
look better now than when they did when
they came out so there's a great
advantage I have forgot where you came
from England talked to lupa about what
he's learned over the years as far as
what the character means to fans saying
I've met thousands of fans whose memory
of Nightmare on Elm Street is not as a
horrible violent film they have great
fond memories of watching it with their
mums and dads and brothers and sisters
they have these memories of a family
experience can Robert Englund ever
really say goodbye to Freddy Krueger as
of right now his answer is a definite
maybe
in 2018 England appeared on the
Halloween episode of the sitcom the
Goldbergs is Freddy it was the first
time that he played the character since
appearing in Freddy vs. Jason in 2003
but as far as returning to the role for
another movie in the future he's not
sure he can commit to it I need a new
actor to play Freddy because we're gonna
have to do eight of them you know maybe
I might have one left in me but at this
point it would be pretty unrealistic to
expect England to sign on to play Freddy
in eight more films actor Jackie Earle
Haley took on the role for one film in a
2010 reboot but since this is the role
that means more to England than any
other there's a good chance that we'll
see him on screen and in our nightmares
is Freddy once more check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stars
a coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]